our other top story far-left cries to
abolish eyes are now going mainstream in
the Democratic Party with New York
senator Kirsten Gillibrand becoming the
first sitting US senator to publicly
call for its elimination while others
say it needs to change I believe you
should get rid of it start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works I think there's no
question that we've got to critically
re-examine ice and its role and the way
that it is being administered and the
work it is doing and we need to probably
think about starting from scratch I
think we need to abolish ice that seems
really clear use some kind of agency to
deal with immigration but I not that we
should abolish ice we should create
something better something different
that was real what you just saw this
comes after nearly 600 people including
a Democratic congresswoman were arrested
during an immigration protest at a
Senate office building an outgoing
acting ice director Thomas home in
responding to the madness on Fox and
Friends law enforcement they should be
respected these these these men and
women run toward danger when everybody
everybody else is running away
and that's why I've been sickened the
last couple months about the attack on
ice officers also American heroes to
strap back onto their hip everyday are
being vilified by members of Congress in
the media okay Jesse so we were just
looking at that almost kind of in
astonishment we're taking in the news as
it's happening and this seems to have
cycled very quickly in terms of just a
quick progression towards abolishing ice
I don't know if you really would have
liked you said predicted this what five
years ago couple years ago Democrats
were voting to fund the border wall and
now they want to abolish ice it's
political suicide and I cannot believe
they're doing it but at least they're
being honest about how they feel I have
to give them that I mean they don't want
the wall they don't want zero tolerance
they don't want ice they're an open
borders party at this point it's front
and center and you think the second
ranking Democrat in the house keith
Ellison wore a t-shirt that said I don't
believe in borders so it is what it is
this is the Democratic Party now and
socialist Democrats are now taking
action against ice centers across the
country Michelle Malkin documented some
of it they rushed through the
property on the west side shut it down
and actually prevented illegals from
getting in here in front of the judge
now the illegals have to be detained for
an extra six weeks so it's it's just
backfiring and it's just a statin
because the ice agents do so many good
things I think they just rescued 57
illegal immigrants men women and
children on the border they had been
abandoned by the smuggler and it was
about a hundred and eight degrees they
rescued another pregnant illegal alien
female crossing the Rio Grande saved her
life and they don't just do that
apprehensions at the border I mean they
they go after drug hitmen they go after
child smugglers narcotics traffickers on
their ice most-wanted list ms-13 members
criminal alien fugitives wanted for
homicide so you know politically I think
this is a real cancer in their caucus
it's going to hurt them and it's going
to backfire and it just reaffirms
everything Donald Trump has been saying
about securing the border and we need
law and order in this country all right
so Katie hello hello good to see you
good to see ya all right so what do you
think about this because you know you've
been studying this immigration situation
and obviously people want to be
compassionate about children about
families but is it fair to put the whole
onus and the blame on ice to demonize
and then to just sort of in sort of a
knee-jerk reaction without much thought
or deliberation say to abolish it look
this this far-left mob that was
organized by the extremist radical
women's rights or sorry women's March
yesterday that descended on the Senate
heart building they're not interested in
protecting children what they're
interested in is abolishing ice and in
declaring that entering this country
illegally is not a crime that is what
they want Linda Sarsour yesterday who
has ties to Lewis Farrakhan by the way
who leads the women's March said when
one woman is not free in this country
none of us are free in this country that
is about sovereignty and when if you get
rid of ice you're eliminating an
extremely important tool that we have in
this country to defend our sovereignty
when it comes to what ice does yes
immigration enforcement is important the
federal government has very few
responsibilities immigration enforcement
border security is one of those
responsibilities they also deal with
child exploitation he
and trafficking terrorism prevention
they are not just an immigration outlet
even though that is an extremely
important part of what they do and
moving forward on this issue if
Democrats want to decide that this is
something they're going to make
mainstream as they have with Senator
Gillibrand senator Elizabeth Warren
jumping into this this mob yesterday
then they need to own it because so far
they tried to say that this is a far
lefting this is not the mainstream of
democratic party it absolutely is and I
think voters are going to take notice of
that all right one hello well I don't
know where to start except to say it's
not true as Jesse was a Sarah Oh
Democrats just want open words I think
that's the invitation here the reality
is that ice is just I think 15 years old
it was started created of course after
9/11 and what you get is a situation
where it's grown widely beyond anybody's
expectation and now not so much involved
with what we intended which was stopping
international terrorists from entering
the country and the like in the
aftermath of 9/11 now they're involved
with things like forcibly separating
children from parents these kind of
raids that have scared people throughout
the country I thought conservatives were
the ones who came up with the phrase
jackbooted thugs to describe government
agencies going overboard not respecting
individual rights in this country so now
you see people standing up and saying
hey this isn't right we just had the man
who was the spokesman for her ice out in
San Francisco resign 17 years in the
government Kimberly sure military DHS
everything he says you know what these
people are spreading lies about
immigrants they're asking me to lie for
them and I can't do it
that's an indication of the kind of
animus now that's being generated the
problem is that under President Trump
what you get is a situation we're
dealing with immigrants has become
criminalized all the immigrants are
criminals as opposed to dealing with the
fact that you need to have safety and
humane treatment and make sure that our
borders are enforced that's very
different than applying a military
answer to a human problem
specific about those that come in and
enter the country illegally and
especially those that have criminal
records or criminal recidivists that
have been on a revolving door internally
you saw at the Kate Steinle case and
nobody is opposed to immigrants we are a
nation built on immigrants it just seems
that all of a sudden this came out of
the shadows Greg like ice it has a PR
problem the hypocrisy is tiresome the
only reason why the Democrats care now
is because Trump is president these
problems existed and were exacerbated
under President Obama you saw an influx
influx of illegal immigrants coming in
and now Donald Trump is trying to deal
with the problem I have a piece of
advice for liberals rather than accuse
these agents of being inhumane and
ripping children from the mothers
breasts and all that stuff
focus on ideas and not people because
what you're doing is you always start at
step one abolish step two is see step
one there is never a solution right so
it's always it this is not a democratic
party it's a child's party because if
the solution they have there these are
children's solutions to adult problems
they are not practical they're they're
emotional they do not factor in the
consequences if they believe that in
this in this case that law enforcement
is the problem and not the work that
they're trying to do which is to prevent
a problem then put your money where your
mouth is abolish law enforcement in your
sanctuary city all right if you believe
that if law enforcement is an issue why
don't you try it where it matters
closest to you and see how it works
I believe that anybody who was there in
that in that I don't know mob actually
felt the consequence of their actions
removing barriers and bore a border so
that they feel it they would feel
differently but they don't have to
that's the beauty of America is you can
have a stupid idea because everybody
else with good ideas is protecting you I
don't think it's about thuggish behavior
you just said that they were inhumane
they are that's what I'm saying is what
people are complaining about although
that's that's what you get here Greg is
a situation where there have been
creating and investigations into black
sites into abusive people coming over
the border by this group that really has
very little accountability very little
supervision because they were put in
place to deal with the aftermath of 9/11
not
evidence of the placards I personally
wait don't be [ __ ] secondly I don't
know you don't know you're just saying
people are saying that's what people are
saying you miss serious people people
saying what we're talking about is
what's being reported Greg you're not on
the border and I'm not on the border so
what we're doing I would love to see so
what I'm saying to you is we need people
who can in fact deal with immigration as
opposed to making everybody into a
criminal
they're not our country illegal is a
crime that is that's correct
Wow we're doing this today all day I
love it